une nouvelle étude fort intéressante qui
est paru récemment qui montre que ne pas
petit déjeuner pu avoir des conséquences
sur notre santé cardio vasculaires en
fait on parle de 87 % de plus de risques
de mourir d'une maladie cardiovasculaire
c'est énorme je disais mon dieu pourquoi
alors on a décidé d'inviter une des
nutritionnistes y avait l'ua pour nous
éclairer vraiment hot
bonsoir à vous on a toujours dit que
c'était c'était mauvais de ne pas petit
déjeuner mais là on arrive avec un
argument un plus massue on fait
attention au fait plus de chances de
mourir du cac ce zèle et une vraie une
bonne étude de bambins en fait une étude
populationnelle on a pris six mille six
cents et quelques américains qu'on a
suivi pendant vingt ans qu'on appelle
une étude de cohorte moi ça m'interpelle
beaucoup ces études là j'ai fait mon
doctorat en épidémiologie donc dans le
domaine populationnelle donc on suit ces
gens là on a regardé leurs habitudes
alimentaires avec un questionnaire à la
maison on les suit dans le temps et on
regarde le développement de maladies et
mortalité par maladies cardiovasculaires
donc 5 l'une les avc et les
cardiopathies ischémiques
puis on s'est rendu compte que les gens
qui déjà n'est pas aussi 5 % de
l'échantillon ans est assez similaire à
ce qu'on trouve au canada puis au québec
à peu près 5 % des gens qui ne déjeunent
pas du tout ces gens là étaient plus à
risque de développer des d'abord en finn
mortalité par maladies cardiovasculaires
et faut prendre en considération que
quand même des facteurs confondants les
gens qui déjeunent pas en général ils
peuvent grignoter le soir ils peuvent
super plus tard ils consomment davantage
d'alcool ils font moins d'activité
physique
mieux le tabac jeux sur des facteurs
confondants look et qu'il faut tenir
quand il avait lui a justement martin
juneau grand spécialiste du coeur à qui
on a posé la question nous dire que sont
les côte-d'oriens vrai le fait de pas
déjeuner c'est souvent un marqueur de
mauvaises habitudes de vie et c'est paul
c'est pas le fait de ne pas déjeuner qui
amènent des problèmes cardiovasculaires
c'est que ça ça nous signale que c'est
quelqu'un qui a des mauvaises de vie en
général d'ailleurs on le voit bien
ce dont ils font moins d'exercice y
mange moins bien ils sont plus paul et
ils fument plus puydebois plus même avec
des contrôles c'est ici qu'on peut pas
enlever ce biello ce qu'on appelle des
facteurs confondants
alors c'est loin d'être une preuve que
le petit déjeuner le déjeuner est un
repos très important bond lui parce que
ouais et originaux et très dangereux
nationale
weir par l'homme et vous vous dites
attention le petit déjeuner c'est très
important fibres fruits on en mange pas
beaucoup ailleurs justement je trouve
que c'est une belle occasion le déjeuner
de faire le plein de fibres alimentaires
et un lien direct entre la consommation
de fibres et l'attention du risque de
diabète de type 2 de maladies
cardiovasculaires aussi meilleur
contrôle de la glycémie contrôle du
cholestérol sanguin aussi le ldl
cholestérol donc le matin on peut
prendre les grilles anti on peut prendre
des fruits des moments privilégiés pour
prendre cesser ces aliments la source de
nutriments importants produits laitiers
substance il voit son tour ya donc une
belle façon je trouve d'intégrer
davantage de fibres sont des jeunes
porcs ou pour les adeptes du jeune
intermittents on a des données
préliminaires qui sont intéressantes
mais pas encore de données probantes sur
plus de 12 mois qui nous permette comme
nutritionniste de recommander le jeune
intermittence aussi certains mais
déjeuner c'est une façon d'intégrer plus
de calcium de vitamine d des fibres
alimentaires des grilles anti passé
demetri maxence par importe vous
répondre à la question pourquoi des
jeunes événement qu'est ce qu'on doit
manger le bon vieux peu fibres fruits
le déjeuner idéal est ce que parce que
les y en a qui sont partis dans des
modes l'âcreté nous qu'un fruit ou que
ceux sous contrat ouais vous vous
continuez à dire malgré ce mode l'homme
équilibré donnez moi des exemples
équilibre est ce qu'on veut le matin
c'est un indice glissé mais plutôt ferme
donc des grains entiers pas trop de
substances blanche avec confiture c'est
parce que c'est juste des glucides
on veut des protéines les études
démontrent qu'on prend beaucoup de
protéines le soir alors qu'on devrait
mieux les répartir dans la journée 15 20
g de protéines le matin même chose le
midi même chose le soir je vais te tuer
le match
les jeux mais à part d'un jeu ça peut
être un oeuf ça peut être du fromage
cottage ça peut être yugo regret que ça
peut être tofu brouiller les protéines
végétales sont en vol ça peut être des
noix sa fait de la graine de chanvre
donc le plusieurs variantes sont
possibles pour mettre les protéines de
l'avant donc on essaie d'avoir un 15,1 g
de protéines le matin même chose le midi
les gens qui nous écoutent à la maison
ce soit qui ont fait un gros steak de
vars peut-être prendre un peu plus
petites portions le lendemain de mieux
équilibrer les protéines d'avoir un
petit peu plus de protéines au petit
déjeuner mon grand père prenait du jt
que le matin d'ailleurs pourquoi pas une
petite portion de 300 mais blanc on
oublie je le paye le plus possible on
s'est enlevé charline alimentaire
canadien le grès entier on est nuls
avant le griotisme pas dupes un
branchement cdu paix à blé entier ous
églantiers ou encore sap est un bol de
quinoa show sa pédicure y'as excellent
le griot c'est vraiment très très bonne
serial temps on voit le mot entier
saigne entier ça peut dit sarrazin du
quesnoy et les serial koprol à
l'épicerie normes algériennes qui existe
depuis toujours il y en attaque 10%
qu'on recommande les autres sont trop
sucrés ou manque de fibres courtes les
ingrédients on aime soit pas trop de
succès le principal défaut des céréales
à déjeuner ça vaut pour les enfants déjà
miss chose mais si on prend un bol de
céréales et trois quarts et de se pincer
pour gagner non plus alors les gens qui
se disent moi je vais prendre que mon
café puis je ne donnerai pas pour
maigrir
puis comme ça ça va m'aider bref un
matin à peluches
qu'est ce que vous leur dis bien le jeu
intermittents si on le fait je conseille
au moins de repos lieu de différentes
façons de le faire le jaune
intermittents il y en a qui mangent pas
de la journée ils ont un seul repas le
soir entre 16 heures et 20 heures par
exemple et juin toute la journée il y en
a d'autres qui vont manger 2010 à 20h
j'aime mieux ça passe je vois
difficilement comment on peut rencontrer
nos besoins nutritifs avec un seul repas
par jour et c'est prouvé on le voit dans
le ramadan dans différentes cultures que
quand il ya un repose souvent on perd le
contrôle
et c'est là où l'on consomme beaucoup
beaucoup trop d'aliments sa nuit au
sommet ça lui au tour de taille
à moins qu'on soit strict qu'on consomme
vraiment peu d'aliments ce moment est il
vrai que c'est mieux de donc manger plus
le matin le midi que le soir
ben en fait de bien répartir c'est
surtout ça doit vraiment bien répartir
dans la journée puis le principal défaut
des québécois c'est qu'on grignote le
soir après le super c de réconfortant de
sortir un petit quelque chose
en écoutant notre émission web pourquoi
pas le but elle ouvert c'est dans le
doubs est jamais le droit de mon jeu
mais plus tard et puis on grignote sans
fin réelle c'est ça à partir du moment
qu'on cesse de grignoter le soir
meilleur sommeil plus nrj puis perte de
poids série manger des vrais fruits
plutôt que juste ça où il est sûr mais
sakho giuly côté lisse et très bien il
avait lui a dû tricher n'espère 6e
toujours merci à la prochaine